[Music]
thank you
thank you welcome back to this episode
of what's up Prof hello Walter it's nice
to be back eh Yes actually it is
uh it's been a quite a time but it's
what we were weren't sitting on our
Laurels hello Laurels yes we were busy
and I'm happy that we can
push the message now Martin we are
living in such serious times
and I believe the message of the Three
Angels must swell into a loud cry it's
time so that'll be our focus
and nothing else should occupy our
attention that's true so when it comes
to current events
then we will try and keep everybody
updated as to where we are in the Stream
of time
and we have a very important document
coming up the laudato c number two yeah
yeah and uh we will wait until it's
there before we discuss it because
what's the point of speculation if you
don't have it in your hand that's it no
we always don't want to jump the gun yes
that's not preempt what he is going to
say we we can glean a little bit of the
past and then we know where it's heading
and with Bible prophecy we know the 2025
agenda of the conservative Lobby well
we'll look at all of that in the future
but our focus is the Three Angels and
everything has to slot into that that's
everything like you said if we discuss
current events it all has to come back
into what the Three Angels messages
entail and why why are the Three Angels
even necessary they're necessary because
the character of God is misunderstood
and that's why it's very important that
we speak about the character of God and
what it entails but before we do that we
better pray I'll pray for us in this
opening
our heavenly father thank you thank you
for being there for us the whole time
never leaving us and we are heading into
the times that you prophesied will be on
now on our Horizon so we ask that you
help us through these
future episodes and that you also will
Enlighten our minds in this episode and
Keep Us Safe in Jesus name amen amen
what in the character of God is such a
huge topic
you cannot really do justice to it in
one discussion no it will be a study for
eternity it's an eternal study the
character of God and the most
misunderstood being in the entire
universe
is God except in heaven yeah
and where are we are we in the world or
are we mentally in a better place that's
important we are in this world but not
of this world so that means our minds
should be heavenward already and that
means if you want to be there you will
have to understand the character of God
when I was an atheist I wouldn't want to
be with the God that I had pictured in
my mind
and so I think it's important that we
set the stage
for the Three Angels messages by talking
about the Misunderstood character of God
so our title is is God love
because that's what he claims to be
right true
and the Lord says I am the Lord I change
not so let's look at some of these
things
God is love that's what the Bible says
Malachi 3 Verse 6 says for I am the Lord
I change not
therefore ye sons of Jacob are not
consumed now Martin this is a very very
important verse because there is this
idea of dichotomy
the god of the Old Testament versus the
god of the New Testament that's it
a wrathful vengeful God against this
loving Jesus correct it seems like an
oxymoron like a misnomer there's
something amiss
unless you make a deep study of it
and the churches have done a marvelous
job in distorting the character of God
to the point of non-recognition and then
the problem with that is that the
non-believers are looking at this
portrayal of God's character and then
said I don't want anything to do with
this they look at the middle age
portrayal of the character of God as put
forward by the church
and believe that that is God
and then that very Church banned the
Bible in the Middle Ages so that you
couldn't find out what the character of
God was and when they finally had to
capitulate to the Bible actually being
there they created so many versions of
it that nobody knows who God is anyway
and so let's rely on feeling rather
aband upon the word
so God does not change that's very
important that means that the god of the
Old Testament and the god of the New
Testament must be the same
true he's never changed it's never
changed if that is true if that is an
axiom
well then God doesn't change
and it says therefore ye sons of Jacob
are not consumed
hidden in that verse you have mercy
exactly you have benevolence yeah
you have caring
you have love
because if he really was as tyrannical
as he is portrayed the sons of Jacob
would be consumed
now the other question is does God have
favorites
why are the sons of Jacob not consumed
and the others are
there aren't the sons of Jacob often
just as bad as the others exactly the
same all right so we have to look at all
of these aspects it's a very very
interesting verse so first point God
doesn't change
there must be love and benevolence
otherwise everybody would be consumed
because everybody's contrary to what God
says they should be that's true and also
that the fact that he does not change
must give you peace of mind yes because
one day you can be saved and the others
you can be lost if he could change his
mind and if he really is a tyrant well
then he's a tyrant forever it's right
through the bank yes maybe it's a
narcissist well that's an accusation
that is thrown towards God oh yes there
are many that say that God is a
narcissist well let's have a look at
what Richard Dawkins thinks about God
and let me be honest
his thoughts are a duplicate of what I
used to believe okay
now I'm sitting in a different chair now
and I came to a different conclusion
but this is what he had to say maybe you
can just explain who Richard Dawkins is
well Richard Dawkins is the evolutionary
voice in the world
he is the one that swings the scepter in
the great universities of the world
and he wrote many many books is he a
scientist yes yes he is associated with
Oxford University
and Cambridge and Oxford are constantly
in debates about these issues and of
course the issue of God versus uh the
the atheistic view is is very prominent
in their discussions so he's a good
representative of the establishment of
liar learning oh yes and he's received
many many awards and is an acclaimed
author and when he opens its mouth I
think it's jewels that come out of his
mouth but as he speaks so I thought yes
but also he represents then the majority
of people in Higher Learning
in the science ermelier absolutely all
right let's see what he has to say I
think he took the Oxford dictionary and
looked up every adjective that he could
find of a negative nature and applied it
to God so this is what he says the god
of the Old Testament is arguably the
most unpleasant character in the whole
of fiction
so automatically he portrays the
character of God and he puts the whole
doctrine of the Bible in the category of
fiction
and then he says he's jealous and proud
of it a petty unjust unforgiving control
freak a vindictive bloodthirsty ethnic
cleanser a misogynistic homophobic
racist infanticidal genocidal felicidal
pestilence or
megalomaniacals sadomasochistic
capriciously malevolent bully I'm glad I
didn't have to pronounce any of those
[Laughter]
well it doesn't leave it there a little
bit later he goes to the portrayal of
God in the New Testament and he says it
is unfair to attack such an easy target
the god hypothesis should not stand or
fall with its most unlovely
instantiation yave
nor his insipidly opposite Christian
face gentle Jesus Meek and Mild
well that puts the god in the New
Testament portrayal and the god of the
Old Testament portrayal in the same
category pathetic right that's what he's
now we would consider this a highly
Blasphemous statement
but this is what he honestly believes
and the question is
why does he believe it that's the main
thing yes
and why did I believe it when I was an
atheist and an evolutionist
and also at the University teaching the
very things that Dawkins stands for
why did I believe that too well so we
have to dig a little bit deeper and find
out why he believes that and why did I
believe it
it carries on after quoting a Catholic
lady who had been traumatized by the
Catholic teaching on hell he writes
I was moved by her letter and
suppressing a momentary and ignoble
regret that there is no hell for those
nuns to go to
replied that she should trust in her
reason as a great gift which she unlike
less fortunate people obviously
possessed
so a lady wrote to him who had been
traumatized by the doctrine of Hell
which was taught by the nuns because in
the schools the nuns give the religious
instruction
and that's exactly why I was an atheist
and thought that God was a bully a
tyrannical tyrant
and applied all the adjectives that he
used as well yes because they I remember
in your testimony yes the nuns were
telling that of your deceased mother now
I have good news for Dawkins he doesn't
have to worry about it because the Bible
knows nothing about the hell that the
churches speak of anyway true
so he's somewhere on the wrong track
now the doctrine that he is attacking
here and that gives him this impression
of God
is obviously a false Doctrine
when you read the Bible you do not find
this Doctrine that's it you can misread
the Bible
and assume this Doctrine
but a deep study will show you that
there is no such thing as an Ever
burning hell the Wicked Will consume
away that's it they become Ash they will
be ashes under your feet there will be
no more
such part of the wine of Babylon and
we'll get to those okay red now the
question is if the Wicked Will consume a
way then is God genocidal does he want
to get rid of a certain group of people
and if so why
so Richard let me tell you
that your anger is Justified but it is
misdirected
he is angry at the doctrine of the
church not at the doctrine of the Bible
furthermore Dawkins has no kind of words
for the Protestant preachers of the day
quoting most of the mega preachers with
their Dominion theology
who Advocate a Reconstructionist model
openly advocating a Christian theocracy
for America
now that is very interesting
particularly in the times
because this is exactly what they are
doing and this is where it's ending and
this is where it's heading and he's
vehemently opposed to it now I believe
the Bible and I'm vehemently opposed to
it exactly so if you just put it in the
right context and you understand the
character then you can
put the anger toward it where it's
supposed to where does the anger belong
does it belong at the feet of the god of
the Bible or does it belong
or does it belong to the very ones that
seem to want to represent him the
churches yes
so they want a Christian theocracy for
America where they enforce their
doctrines
and the question is is it biblical what
they want to enforce some of it might be
it will always be because 99 will be
good yeah is that one percent poison
uh-huh and then you will have a problem
because then you will have to choose
between their understanding and the
portrayal in the Bible
so this should set the stage as to why
people have turned against God
they have managed also to ridicule the
Bible yeah
so that it becomes irrelevant
so it means a very very deep study to
actually discern what the conflict is
all about
but very definitely God's character is
under attack under attack the portrayal
of God's character in the world
is
horrendous so the question is
is God love
with everything that it entails
now Martin I was walking on the way here
this morning
and I stopped at the bush with the
tiniest little flowers on it very
unassuming
and I happened to take a closer look at
the detail
and the the absolute magnificence that
is built into that little flower that
nobody gives a second gaze and you just
walk this walk past it
and I looked at the detail and I thought
what kind of what kind of Creator would
create something so Sublime yeah if you
take now that same flower and you take a
magnifying glass of or even a microscope
then it even becomes more The Depths
becomes unfathomable
anyway we read in 1 John 4 verse 8 he
that loveth not knoweth not God
that's a profound statement so if you do
not have love in you then you do not
know God
so if you say God is not love
then obviously you're not understanding
who he is and then we have to look at
the various aspects of love because what
people consider Love Today is often not
love but passion and when tested it
falls apart
that's why we have so many disastrous
relationships in the world today and
they're getting worse and worse and
worse
and then the Bible says
definitively God is love
so you can only love if you are
controlled by the power of God
so obviously if the Bible says God is
love we must understand what is love
what is love and why why does God act
the way that he acts why does he come
across sometimes as a Stern task master
why does he come across as a destroyer
or what has that got to do with love we
have to we have to be very careful how
we look at that issue now verse 16 says
and we have known and believed the love
that God has to us God is love
and he that dwelleth in love dwelleth in
God and God in him
so if you have true love
then you must have an association with
God otherwise you have a semblance of
love
or a false concept of love that just put
new meaning in when you are a
representative of God and his character
yes if you have the wrong idea of God
and his character then you can be
portraying the wrong image all right now
Martin I've been looking
at the presidential debates
and when I look at these people that are
debating each other they don't give each
other a chance to talk
there is a constant interrupting and
screaming at each other
there is there is total chaos as far as
that is concerned and the ones that
you're supposed to be working with that
are apparently on your side because
they're all in the same party become
model enemies
inside of that
there's no Unity no there's no just
after the election then there's supposed
to be Unity on these people that says
you look at this chaos and you say to
yourself okay do they really have a
concept of God and what it means to to
love
and how do you love
is it failure love is it Association
love what is agape I mean we've spoken
about that many many times the same with
um is it it must be other scentedness so
it's not selfish it's all of these now
when you have these debates these
presidential debates
are you concerned about the welfare of
the opposite party or are you are you
approaching it from a selfish
perspective and how many times do they
become personal and not even attack the
situations I hear they called Donald
Trump Donald Duck now
because he's ducking and Diving the
issues
anyway
so what does it mean when the Bible says
God is love obviously it's selfless
Agape or love
all right so the Bible is very clear
that if you have the correct
understanding of love and you exercise
the correct understanding of love then
you must have an association with God
who is the source of that love
1 John 2 verse 5 says but whoso keepeth
his word in him verily is the love of
God perfected hereby know we that we are
in him so here's a little proof text for
us how do you know
well you have to keep the word that's it
and what's the word
what is the word this is the word
this is the word you have to be in
harmony with this word and now Martin
how many people or even how many
churches are in harmony with this word
to the law and to the testimony
if I speak not according to this word
there's no light in them okay and if
they have no light then they have no
love either no all right because the
love is the light and love
so the the age-old animosity that
existed between Cain and Abel
still exists today
and Cain will do his utmost to slay Abel
yeah why because
Abel kept the word
and Kate didn't no and that means enmity
enmity and the enmity is actually
towards God but it's taken out on your
well they can't get to him get to the
nearest thing possible he's
representative
all right so that's what the Bible says
now we ask the question is God love when
you look at the portrayals in the Old
Testament
and you look at it with the glasses that
Dawkins had on well then he's a bully
that Tyrant even yes
so let's go to the New Testament we're
talking about the God that doesn't
change
now Dawkins separated the two yeah you
said that the one is actually the softy
pathetic one and it's a different
portrayal of the same evil one that you
had in the Old Testament
now let's have a Look what Jesus had to
say to the Pharisees
but woe unto you Pharisees
for ye tithe and mint and Rue and all
manner of herbs and pass over judgment
and the love of God these all key to
have done and not to leave the other
undone
wasn't there some very deep thoughts in
there
now remember that the Pharisees were
portrayal of God's Church weren't they
yeah they were the representative they
were actually there to portray God's
character to the world correct so what
the Pharisees did and what they taught
and how they led the people was an
expose of the character of God
but they left out two things
judgment
and the love of God
they had a lot of love for self
thank God I'm not like that one so they
elevated themselves
and they appropriated all the blessings
to themselves and all the curses to the
others
is that love no that's selfishness it
should exactly it should be that other
way around they should want to betray
all the other good things to the other
people all right so Martin are you
saying to me that they distorted the
love of God
differently didn't God want them to be a
light unto the Gentiles didn't he say
that over and over how did they treat
the Gentiles they treated them like
lepers how did they treat the Samaritans
yeah terrible didn't even I mean yeah
they didn't even want to look upon them
and never mind now the Bible says while
we were yet sinners God died for us
right
so that is love
loving the unlovable
and I think God in his wisdom
uh sends us many unlovables
and he puts many of them into the church
and that's a test are we going to be
like the Pharisees are we going to take
the whole background of this individual
that's so unlovable into account
overlook
all the objectionable character traits
and try and reach the the person that he
can actually become once exposed to the
love of God if you take in Jesus day why
were the Pharisees so
vehemently opposed to him because he was
bringing all those characters into the
church he was taking the unlovables and
turning them into lovables right and
they couldn't stand it they couldn't
handle it why didn't he take the
educated
fancy
well-robed Pharisees
no he rebuked them so there were two
things that they ignored judgment
fairness were there fair in their
assessment as to who was to be saved and
who was not to be saved no did they use
the correct measure
no they didn't they used their own
measure not God's measure they designed
their own measure so they distorted
what the scriptures actually said do the
modern churches do the same if modern
people do that okay
and so they misunderstood the love of
God and then he says this you ought to
have done
and you shouldn't have left the other
undone you can still pay your tithe and
you can do whatever you have to do your
rituals as long as you do not ignore
judgment
if you have judgment then you must have
a standard of judgment that's it
messenger you see judgment
has become a negative word to most
people all right so if you want to have
a judgment
then axiomatically you need a law that's
it because you cannot be a judge without
law because what are you going to judge
by
you have to judge by the law
and the love of God
so these look like two opposites right
that's the problem but they have to both
be there
all right let's see what God says about
himself Exodus 20 verse 6 he says
showing Mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my Commandments
how do you love God by keeping his
Commandments but why would you want to
keep his Commandments out of fear
because you love him
no so you don't keep his Commandments
out of fear but you keep his
Commandments because you love him now
why would you love someone
would you love the the unlovable ones
would you love them God would yeah he
loved the unlovable why would you love
him why would you love him you need to
understand because you care for them
because you and can can relate to all
right so if you want to love him you
need to agree with him
God loves those that don't agree with
that disagree as well I'm sure he loves
tokens right did he die for him as well
all right so he loves Dawkins and he
loved me
and then he showed me his character in
the Bible
and I read that character with new
glasses
totally new glasses and I got the
opposite of what I got before yeah
and so I learned that you can you can
love God
but to manifest that love you have to
keep his Commandments that's it there's
a work to be done as well it's not just
a thought all right it's an action as
well now Martin if you love God and it's
manifested by keeping his Commandments
then the Commandments must be a
reflection of love true it must be a
commandment of love it cannot be
separated it can't because the thing is
Mercy
is also a portrayal of love all right
now Commandments is that a law yes
all right so can it be a standard of
judgment yes
so judgment and Commandments cannot be
separated
okay but if you
want to be justified
all of us would like to be justified
declare just declared just so then it
can be a positive thing if you are the
right side all right Deuteronomy 7 verse
9 know therefore
that the Lord thy God he is God the
faithful God which keepeth Covenant and
mercy with them that love him and keep
his Commandments to a thousand
Generations basically he's saying
forever
[Music]
okay
so Martin
he is a just God he is a faithful God he
keeps his promises he keeps his Covenant
now Covenant
is a document of agreement it's a legal
document actually between two parts two
parties so it's actually part of a law
and he keeps it
and he keeps it with those that love him
and keep his Commandments
so in other words the Commandments the
Covenant
the
agreement they have to be a unit you
cannot separate them and he's keeping
his side of this of the bargain yeah
well that's what he claims
all right so we've discovered what the
problem is with the church in Jesus's
time
they had all the rituals they had a
wrong understanding they neglected
judgment and the love of God
and the love of God includes loving the
unlovable
but it doesn't exclude judgment no
therefore the unlovable must come into
harmony with his love and therefore that
must be portrayed in keeping the
Commandments is that what it teaches
it's exactly what it teaches okay
Deuteronomy 30 verse 16.
and then I command thee this day to love
the Lord thy God
Martin If somebody walks up to you and
says I command you to love me
it's gonna work no not gonna work in
fact it's going to be the exact opposite
you're gonna Rebel immediately what tell
me what to do I'm not gonna do that
right
come find yourself another sucker but as
for me
uh I'm not going to play that game all
right
so I command thee this day to love the
Lord thy God to walk in his ways and to
keep his Commandments and his statutes
and his judgments that thou mayest live
and multiply
is a very important point so is keeping
his Commandments his statutes and his
judgments necessary
in order to live and multiply yeah to
have a lot to live happily to have
Freedom okay so it's life associated
with keeping the Commandments that's it
and then he says I command you to love
God
I command you to love me I command you
to love me Martin
not going to work
you have to mess up you can you must
understand no or you must have this
feeling that there's something something
more to it more to this all right so
let's look at it from another angle
let's say he puts it all on the table
he says this is what I want
and I'm going to show it to you in great
Grandeur in fact I'm going to go to the
top of a mountain I'm going to make the
mountain shake and Quack I'm going to
write it in stone and I'm going to write
it with my own finger and I'm going to
give it to you and I want you to talk
about it when you get up and I want you
to talk about it with your children and
I want you to talk about it when you go
to bed and I want you to study it
through
and he gives it to you and you ask
yourself the question
okay why must I do this
once you have studied it you are
actually studying the character of God
aren't you yeah for sure all right so
why would God command you not to kill
your neighbor
for your own good
and for your neighbor's good okay is he
also commanding the neighbor not to kill
you then exactly
so in other words in order to live you
must let live that's it
why would he command you not to steal
your neighbor's Goods maybe throw your
bit for you and for your neighbor
because how would you feel if your
neighbor steals you're going to say
right why would he command you
to leave your neighbor's wife alone
very good and so that he's you can leave
your wife alone with your hair stand on
edge if your neighbor
I don't think you need my hair
all right so if you study it through
then you must realize that these laws
are are just yeah
they're not they're not burdensome
unless you want to be a criminal then
that burdensome well if I look at this
verse that you just read
if you're just swing it around and you
ask a question
if you want the god to bless you if you
want to have a happily what must you do
then he commands you to keep the
statutes all right so by studying his
requirements you can get an idea of his
character
is that correct definitely
okay so when he says to you I want you
to love me
is actually saying to you study my
requirements and see if you can live
with those yeah
and uh if you if you say no I don't want
to live with them then ask yourself the
question do I want to live without them
yeah do I want to live with a
consequence yes because if I live
without them that means I give free
reign to my neighbor
to come and mess with my wife with my
goods to lie to me to steal to me to
dishonor my name all of those things now
if that applies to humanity wouldn't it
apply to God who made the rules in the
first place definitely
all right so why would you want another
God if there is no other God yeah
okay so I think we can establish that if
you want to follow this command to love
God then you need to understand his
Commandments and his statutes and his
judgments because they are conditional
to your life
and to your prosperity
and the Lord thy God shall bless thee in
the land whether thou goest to possess
it so he simply has a simple statement
of fact do this and you'll be happy
that's actually what this exactly what
this is
if for instance the whole congregation
was standing there and asking me what
must we do that we can be in the favor
of God then he can answer I command you
to keep his Commandments to stay in his
statutes that's right good it doesn't
Force you but there are consequences if
you don't do it
Psalms 119 127 therefore I love thy
Commandments above gold yea above fine
gold
when you love his Commandments then
axiomatically you love him
exactly and if that is your attitude
then it won't be burdensome then it
never it's a it's never a heavy thing so
how important are the in Commandments
well
life and death all right so the greatest
display
of the power and Grandeur of God
was at Sinai yeah
where the law was presented and given
and written in stone which means it's
immovable I am the Lord I change not not
so I think we can establish that if you
love The Commandments because you've
studied them
and you're not studying them from a
selfish point of view you're studying
them from a benevolent point of view
both in the giving and in the receiving
then automatically you will love God
you know on that mountain when it was
given it's actually a gift that God gave
yes
all right
let's go a little bit deeper
Daniel
this is Daniel's prayer in chapter 9
verse 4 and I prayed unto the Lord my
God and made my confession and said O
Lord the great and Dreadful God keeping
the Covenant and mercy to them that love
him and to them that keep his
Commandments is it a a refrain that
recurs over and over in the Bible
right through from Old Testament right
through New Testament can you ignore it
no
it's the central theme right it's a
central theme
all right
so he keeps the Covenant
is a merciful god
and in order to receive all this Mercy
you must love him
but in order to love him to manifest
that love you have to keep the
Commandments that's it in other words
you have to come into harmony with his
will yeah I challenge anybody in the
world
to go and look at the Ten Commandments
and to show me where they are
unreasonable
people will try especially in the first
four but that's pertaining to God right
that's potential so start with the with
the last six and see this is your
relationship that you have to have with
your neighbor
therefore what must your relationship be
with God you must show him respect
that's it and you mustn't have other
lovers because they're fake
all right so jumping to the New
Testament John 14 verse 15 if you love
me keep my Commandments is there any
change between what the Old Testament
says and what the New Testament says can
we honestly and Faithfully record that
God hasn't changed with regard to his
Commandments definitely 100 no change
right whether it comes out of the mouth
of Jesus as in this case if you love me
keep my Commandments or out of the mouth
of Yahweh there's no difference no
difference no difference same God okay
just make sure verse 21 says he that
hath my Commandments and keepeth them he
it is that loveth me
so if you don't keep the Commandments
you don't love God
that's it and it's not the selfish God
that says this it's just a fact it's
that's how it is the consequences show
you this all right so in other words the
Commandments say Live and Let Live
Live and Let Live do unto others as you
would have them do unto you
that's the Commandment that's love for
your neighbor
and the same applies to love for God do
what it says in the first
four Commandments and you will be
showing that you love God
you will show that you agree there's
only one God
you will not have an idol you will not
blaspheme his name and you will want to
spend time with him his time that he
designates
and not that someone else designates
so no difference
I am the Lord I change not does it apply
yeah
John 15 verse 10 if you keep my
Commandments you shall abide in my love
even as I have kept my father's
Commandments and abide in his love
so the portrayal of God in the New
Testament Jesus
is saying that he hasn't changed one
iota from the god of the Old Testament
that what the requirements were of the
god of the Old Testament were kept by
Jesus and therefore he requires the same
of you that's it he did it and he showed
what the consequences is that the god
that you have to love God and you should
do the same you should do the same so if
you keep the Commandments
then you will abide in his love
in other words you will stay there
you will you will remain there
and he gave us an example
the requirements of the Old Testament
were fulfilled by me therefore I want
you to fulfill them too I didn't come
and take it away to make it easier now
for you I came to show you that that is
the Old Testament stands right and it
can be done is it unreasonable of him to
ask this not at all let's go to one John
5 verse 3 for this is the love of God
that we keep his Commandments and his
Commandments are not Grievous no
therefore is it unreasonable of him to
ask this it's a command it's the
Commandments of Love
how can it be Grievous but Thomas akina
says that it's reasonable for you to
secure for yourselves the goods of
others to satisfy your needs we see that
in a way we live quite often yes that's
a diseased religion that says something
like that yeah because it's totally
contrary to the word of God and yet
these so-called Saints are the ones that
give us natural law on which all modern
law is based yeah it's amazing we've
spoken about this many times
they take away 10 laws and they have to
have to write thousands and they don't
keep any of them and they don't keep it
and they can't even keep anybody safe
all right what is happening in the world
today
on the cities in Turtle chaos the police
have been sent away we don't need them
anymore because do what your wealth has
become the law
and what do you have total chaos or
people happy with it no everybody is
and so the question is Martin
once they become so unhappy that they
cannot stand it anymore which is where
they basically are now
are they going to make Draconian laws
and God will get the blame yes
definitely and will they make their laws
or will they make God's laws they make
they'll make their laws they'll make
some of God's laws but then they'll have
their own laws in develop their own
interpretation yeah
all right Martin we've established if
you can imagine one city in the whole
world that will keep the Ten
Commandments won't everybody want to go
and live there it would be marvelous
it'll be Heaven because heaven will be
wherever all the Commandments are kept
all right it's a mutton this is the
bottom line
if you want to understand the love of
God you have to understand his law
and once you've established that the law
portrays love
and you love the law above fine gold
because wow if everybody keeps it you're
safe from interference from your
neighbor
then Martin then you will love God
automatically I just had a thought so if
anybody tells you don't preach the
Commandments preach the love of God
that's a misnomer that's an oxymoron
because you can't do the one without the
other that's it okay
so we've shown this a hundred times
already but we'll show it 101 times
Maybe 102.
until people finally get it so if you
look at the character of God and the
character of the law and you look it up
in the Bible you will see that it says
that God's character is just Romans 3
verse 26 and it'll say the law is just
Romans 7 verse 2.
and so you can go down God is through
the law is true God is pure the law is
pure God is light the law is light God
is faithful
the law is faithful God is good the law
is good God is spiritual the law is
spiritual God is Holy the law is holy
God is truth the law is truth God is
life the law is life God is righteous
the law is righteousness
god is perfect the law is perfect God is
forever the law is forever
but now Martin the law is not a person
no it's a set of rules it's a mirror yes
it's a mirror of God's character all
right so if you look in the mirror and
you fall in love with yourself then
you've actually Fallen if you look at
this Mary you fall in love with God
that's it because that's what it
portrays that's his image and if that
mirror is showing you things that you're
not doing then you're not in harmony
with that character all right so you
cannot separate the law from the
character of God
now if you love the law if you're in
love with a book
um
isn't it better to love the actual
person that's it
all right
so love the law you automatically love
God you cannot separate them no because
that also becomes problem problemsome
all right now what theoretically if
somebody doesn't keep the law
everybody's happy right if somebody
kills your child you're perfectly happy
because somebody's finally killed your
child that's ridiculous right you're
going to be up in arms you're going to
scream for justice that's it we need to
discuss this yeah
in some detail in future
so if anybody transgresses the law
everybody is up in arms but nobody wants
to keep the law then how does that work
Martin That's How well what about doing
away with the law entirely yeah no
Jesus took away the law but he just said
keep it how could he have taken away if
he says keep it that's a misnomer
so Martin let's look at the other aspect
the wrathful deity the wrath of God
Romans 1 verse 18.
for the wrath of God is revealed from
Heaven against all ungodliness and
unrighteousness of men
who hold the truth in unrighteousness
now we just read that God is righteous
and that the law is righteous right
righteousness is portrayed in the law
and righteousness is the character of
God
and the wrath of God is against
unrighteousness
so that will be against lawlessness
that's against lawlessness all right now
Martin if somebody comes and bludgeons
your child to death
are you going to be angry yeah for sure
are you going to be wrathful yeah are
you going to want to do something about
it or have something done about it you
want Justice to be to be done they want
Vengeance to be taken on this person
that did it then why do you want to
scream at God if he has the same
sentiments that's it very good huh so Mr
Dawkins
if God is a God of Justice
and God wants to uphold righteousness
why are you screaming now
why are you giving him all kinds of
names
and negative connotations
if he is going to uphold righteousness
then you say should say thank God there
is someone at least who is trying to
keep sanity in this world right
Deuteronomy chapter 3 verse 1.
then we turned and went up the way to
Bashan and OG the king of bassan came
out against us he and all his people to
battle at address
and then verse 3 says so the Lord Our
God delivered into our hands OG also the
king of bassan and all his people and we
smote him until none was left to him
remaining
now there's a genocidal God yeah that
gave an order
to wipe out Ogg and everything that
pertains to him don't wipe them out
so now this is a vengeful this is a
vengeful horrible wrathful genocidal God
you could look at it like that but you
could ask yourself the question why
would a God who says that he is love
give a command like that
is it possible that organ is entire
nation had passed the point of no return
yes there's no return from where they've
gone so they cannot return they've
already passed that point where God's
mercy was they became so evil
and so murderous and so perverse
is that they were a curse to humanity
and the only solution was to remove them
or else all Humanity would eventually
become contaminated Martin if the evil
in the world
were to be allowed to go unchecked yes
wouldn't eventually the whole world
become evil that's you have glimpses of
the this happening where places where
they've just let people carry on and not
implement the law
what happened
it's actually chaos so here's another
Point Martin
in this portrayal here in the Old
Testament
God was enacting a theocracy
it was a a theater yes it was a stage
set yeah it was something that the
Nations should Witness
like a soapy you switch on the
television and you look at the next
episode here's a portrayal
of what God requires he requires
absolute obedience to his Commandments
because any transgression of The
Commandments means pain to someone yeah
and he wants No Pain No More Tears no
more pain that means no transgression
because any transgression is going to
cause pain if somebody's gonna kill
something that belongs to you you're
going to have pain so nobody May kill
right nobody May steal nobody May lie
they must only be truth then there will
be no pain
so here was an enactment
and he enacted it not only with the
Nations around
the the most wicked of them but even
amongst his own people yeah
because there's no shadow of turning
with him what applies to the one applies
to the other it applies to everyone it
changes not correct but here he had a
professed people that said everything
you have commanded we will do yeah of
course they didn't no but but
nevertheless they professed yes isn't
that the church that's the church the
church is supposed to profess everything
that you said we will do because you
believe it you're convicted of it
doesn't mean that you will not stumble
and fall and doesn't mean that that the
persons in the church do that but the
church has to acknowledge
this is what we'll do all right was God
just then if we look at it from that
point yes where these people were
sacrificing their own children where
they were torturing people relentlessly
where they were breaking every single
commandment in the most horrendous way
and even bringing that into their
religious systems that God said this
system is so corrupt and so evil it
needs to be eradicated because this will
never be allowed to exist in my future
heaven exactly this was a portrayal of
this has to be done because this was is
the same that will be done to have
heaven
without disdain all right let's ask
another question did Justice demand the
execution of OG yes and everything that
pertains yes because everything had
become corrupt yes all right we look at
it from that way
and let's go back and look at the
Covenant with Abraham
Genesis 15 from verse 13. and he said
unto Abraham
now of a surety that thy seed shall be a
stranger in the land that is not theirs
and Shall Serve them and they shall
afflict them 400 years that's a type
we are actually in a Land of slavery yes
we are in land of slavery all right and
God is permitting it
and the situation is supposed to bring
us closer to him and therefore change
our character characters into a
similitude of his right
so they were strangers and we are
strangers in this world
and they shall afflict them 400 years
that's the time
and also that Nation whom they Shall
Serve will I judge and afterwards shall
they come out with great substance
that's a promise that's a promise of
Deliverance do we have a promise of
Deliverance yes so this is a type right
and thou shalt go to thy fathers in
peace Thou shalt be buried in a good old
age
You Won't See Redemption you will die
but in the fourth generation they shall
come hither again for the iniquity of
the amorites is not yet full
so God did not bring this nation out of
Egypt
under his control under his power
and use them as an example to the world
of what will happen to those that reject
his law
and he says that he's not going to
permit them to wipe out those Nations
whose land they were going to occupy the
Canaanites who were the most evil of all
the people on the planet the most
perverse
because the iniquity was not yet full
how much time did they allow them 400
years
400 years is that long suffering imagine
a city in the world today that has no
laws that is allowed to still go on for
400 years uh do we have this interesting
debate in the United States at the
moment Lawless cities as opposed to
non-lawless cities interesting you see
that's why I'm bringing it up if you
look on so you can already see where
it's heading
it will be towards The Godly one but it
will ever sting all right
now Martin if a city really becomes
Wicked
would God have the right to remove it
like Sodom and Gomorrah I was thinking
about that just earlier
the if you take the previous verse that
we read about them that the org and the
Bashan
it's similar to when God said to lot
he's going to destroy Sodom and Gomorrah
and he said no but what if they sell
people that's not
um so that's the first thought that
comes up when you read that section of
OG as well
weren't there any people that might
still have changed all right did did God
apply that discussion that you have now
with Abraham when it came to Sodom
exactly didn't he say what if there are
50 and it came down to what if there are
ten yeah and in the end how many came
out three three so that's the same when
God is merciful for 400 years do you
think when it's up that he knows that
there's nobody else that puts us all
right does he have the right to act that
way isn't he the Creator yeah all right
let me ask another question is it an act
of love and mercy to eliminate them yes
exactly right it is what if they were
going to murder every single one of you
isn't that that the police today or the
military don't they assume the right to
eradicate someone who is such a danger
that he will kill everybody around him
that's it you have to take him out you
have to
now if that is perfectly acceptable in
the times that we are living in how much
more so in the Judgment of God how
merciful was he 400 years and but isn't
it interesting just what you mentioned
that there are very many people in in
society today that don't want the police
to have that correct they don't want to
live in lawlessness then they want to be
like Sodom yeah
all right so the wrath of God towards
the Lawless ones OG Sodom Gomorrah you
can go through it the amalekites
whenever God gave the command it's over
then they were to be eradicated now in
the case of other nations like the
Philistines for example did he eradicate
them all no no
it didn't
and when it came to the moabites or any
one of them did eradicate them all no no
there were only some the way he said
eradicate them all they had become so
corrupt
that it was necessary
to eradicate yeah it like you said
earlier this is a type of where we're
heading towards if you want to go to
heaven this cannot exist as a threat to
the church and remember that was a
theocracy it was an enactment of a
greater reality we're not living in a
theocracy now we're going to go back to
a theocracy because
the theocracy that will finally be
implemented one is the Heavenly one
but not here on Earth no that'll be a
false one that's the thing so Dawkins
relax
there's another question that I think
people might have what about the way in
what in which they got rid of these
nations well very often God himself got
rid of them they didn't even have to
lift a little finger yeah but we must
also remember that sometimes
the people that had to do the
eradication went beyond what God was
asking of them correct well you see when
God eradicated someone it was quick yeah
000 they were alive one moment they were
dead the next moment the Syrian Army
or when he fought on behalf of God's
people he eradicated them not like the
Assyrians that tortured people to death
slowly God is not a tyrant or a monster
he eradicated them his people might have
gone too far in some some cases but not
God but still the original purpose of
God wanting that eradicated was not
wrong in other words there was a mass
murderer on the loose
and he had to be eradicated before he
destroyed everyone that's it that's the
way we should see it now the wrath of
God
is not only towards idolaters
but the wrath of God is against anything
that is contrary
to his defined will
so we look at the Wrath towards
idolaters and we look at one Samuel 15
verse 18. and the Lord sent thee on a
journey and said go and utterly destroy
the Sinners the amalekites and fight
against them until they be consumed
there's an example
there's a direct command of God
which Dawkins would interpret as
genocide
right
where he says go and destroy the Sinners
the amalekites now he defines the
amalekites of Sinners and sin is the
transgression of the law
according to John right
so they were transgressors of God's law
to the
Nth Degree
and they had to be consumed so there was
a command Wipe Out the amalekites they
are recursed upon the Earth and they
will contaminate and Destroy Humanity
get rid of them
their spirit is contagious
and this this command to destroy the
amalekites was given to King Saul right
one Samuel 15 20 and Saul said unto
Samuel
yeah I've obeyed the voice of the Lord
and have gone the way which the Lord
sent me and have brought a gag the king
of amalek and have utterly destroyed the
amalekites
firstly he didn't destroy everything no
because the king is still there God made
such an example of them they weren't
even to take their goods or their
animals they went to enrich themselves
from the products of evil just get rid
of it all it's like taking a pot of gold
and dumping it into the sea very hard
for them to do
because they rather wanted the
contaminated washed money than to do
without it so he brought the Sheep
because he didn't want to sacrifice his
own sheep
and he was selfish
and he didn't kill the king of amalek
and it's obvious that he didn't kill
them all because the amalekite remnants
were still there for a very very long
time so it didn't do what he was told to
do he had to get rid of them all and he
didn't do it
now let's have a look at the death of
Saul
second Samuel 1 12. he and his son were
killed right
and they mourned and wept and fasted
until even for Saul and Jonathan his son
and for the people of the Lord and for
the house of Israel because they were
Fallen by the sword
So eventually Saul was overcome by his
enemies in this case it was the
Philistines that they fought against
and then we read in verse 13 and David
said unto the young man that told him
whence Art Thou
and he answered I am the son of a
stranger in amalekite
now Saul had fallen
and he wasn't dead
but he had been severely wounded and he
knew that he was going to die so he fell
upon his own sword
but that didn't kill him either
so then he called this other guy who
happened to be this one
and he happened to be the son of a
stranger an amalekite yeah
and he killed him he chopped his head
off right
and David said unto him how was thou not
afraid to stretch forth thy hand to
destroy the Lord's anointed and David
called one of the young men and said go
near and fall upon him and he smote him
that he died so he took care of
amalekites he took care of the Amala God
now what's the moral of the story Martin
the moral is if you do not kill the
amalekite he's going to kill you he's
coming back and he's chopping your head
off all right now the Bible defined the
amalekites as Sinners transgression of
the law so let's reduce it to sins and
if you do not kill sin in your life
it's going to kill you yeah you have to
kill it you have to die to self
so is this unjust what has transpired
here I mean what did the man do it did
he did what Saul asked him and if Saul
did what God asked him that man would
have not been there that man would not
have been there no and he probably
wouldn't have had the battle with the
Philistines and lost it exactly
everything would have turned out
differently so one little disobedience
and you have dire consequences yes for
the whole nation yeah because not only
Saul was affected the entire nation was
affected thousands upon thousands
suffered as a consequence
so Martin the moral of the story is if
God is a god of love
then God is a God of Justice as well the
standard of justice is the law and the
law defined sin and once sin reaches a
point of no return then it has to be
eradicated
together with the one who is performing
it
so is this unjust or is this
just it's absolutely just all right
let's compare it a mass murderer is on
the loose
he has an assault rifle he's
indiscriminately killing people left
right and Center is it just for the
police to take him out yes
yes is this what God did yes this is
what God did
but he applied it to a whole nation that
was going to destroy the rest of
humanity if it was permitted to exist
any longer
now let's look at the wrath of God
towards his own people
because God is a fair God he doesn't
have two measures he doesn't have two
standards and requires his church to
exercise Justice and the love of God
didn't we see that
all right let's look at a very
interesting example that is of also very
painful to many in the time that we are
living in
and this comes from Psalm 78 verse 27
and refers to the time when God
permitted the people
to eat flesh that he had withheld from
them in the form of the quails
so he ran flesh upon them as dust
and feathered fowls like as the sand of
the sea so this is Hebrew parallelism
yes so this is also betraying the story
that happened in Exodus correct
and he let it fall in the midst of the
camp round about their habitations so
they did eat and were filled
for he gave them their own desire
and let's just stop there this own
desire that they had was it in harmony
with his will for them no no no because
he did provide correct now he first
provided them
well he provided them once
because they lusted thereof and there
was no rebuke
and then he tried to teach them a better
way and they refused and they lusted
again
and this time there were consequences
so he gave them their own desire
they were not as strange from their lust
they hadn't changed they still lusted
for what was not for their own good now
Martin if the scriptures are correct
then who designed you got it
and if he designed you will he know
what's best for you yes
I am
a diesel engine
he's going to tell me to put diesel fuel
in all right not petrol okay so as your
designer he tells you what's good for
you
but you say to him I don't care I like
the petrol I want to do what I want to
do it's going to give me more vuma so he
says all right I'll tell you what I'll
teach you a lesson
I'll give you what you desire because
you are not estranged from your lust and
we'll see what the consequences are so
you end up with cancer you end up with
all kinds of diseases and you scream to
God for his unfair treatment of you is
that how it works yeah
so God in his wisdom gives you a
blueprint
and it tells you this is what what is
required this is what you are designed
for and let me tell you why
there will be no death in heaven
nobody's going to kill anybody else's
pet
because that person will be very upset
when you kill his pet
so there's going to be no death so
please get used to it that I have
created plants
for your well-being
so the original diet of man was fruits
grains nuts and seeds and then
vegetables were added and that's where
it was supposed to stay there will be no
death the rest is harmful for you I
don't want you to have it but I'm not
estranged from my lust I wanted all
right I'll give it to you is that unfair
of God no
so if a child insists on doing something
that is harmful to it a parent will
sometimes
allow him to go
just far enough
to feel the consequences
and maybe you'll learn a lesson
and then while the meat was yet in the
mouths the wrath of God Came Upon them
and slew the fattest of them and smote
Down The Chosen men of Israel
so here was a retributive action of God
against his own people they wouldn't
listen
there was a theocracy
we are now not living in a theocracy so
God is long-suffering for 400 years and
many generations but the consequences
are horrendous right
and then what does it say
for all this they send still and believe
not for his wondrous works
this is the condition
that Humanity has that's it it's called
The Fallen nature
and God wants to restore that Fallen
nature and in order for that Fallen
nature to be restored you must come into
harmony with his Commandments
and his will now there are 10 moral
statutes
but they don't negate the laws of
physics and the laws of physiology
so he's given Health laws as well
and they need to be obeyed that's it and
not because God is a tyrant
but because it's for your own good and
for your well-being
because it's a god of love and
eventually eventually for the well-being
of everybody around him there was a
preacher
his name was Richard of full he's dead
now
and I met him many many years ago and I
sat in many of his sermons he was a
sweet man I I really liked him
and uh he would always give an example
his wife's name was Betty
and he says if I transgress the laws of
Health
who suffers
Betty suffers because she has to take
care of me so I would bring this into
every sermon who suffers it's Petty that
suffers yes and this is the way it is if
we create this burden everybody else
around us suffers
so part of human nature is to want to
sin still yeah so God is just as
righteous and just with his own people
as he is with the Nations around that is
a very important point and I hope people
understand that because that's what
you've just shown it's not that he's got
favorites and the others are just the
whole time Vietnamese enemies correct
Psalm 78 38 but he being full of
compassion
forgave their iniquity and destroyed
them not yea many a time turn to his
anger away and did not stir up all his
Wrath and that is either true or it's a
lie
did it apply to the Nations didn't he
give them 400 years yeah
it didn't he forgive and didn't he stay
his wrath the same with his own people
the same with his own people so that's
his character
why does he have such bad press modern
so what does The Bible require of us in
the light of this
it's to put on a new self
Colossians 3 from verse 1 and if ye then
be risen with Christ seek those things
which are above where Christ sitteth on
the right hand of God
set your affections on things above not
on things on the Earth
is the law of God kept in heaven yes
definitely because the transgressors
have been removed from Heaven as Satan
and his host being cast out cast out was
he a law breaker yes yes he was a
murderer from the beginning it was a
thief and a liar from the beginning so
that's breaking the law of God right yes
he's out
so if you set your affections on things
above then you must live according to
things above that's it do we have a
record of that yes yes it's in the Bible
right
for ye are dead and your life is hid
with Christ in God
so it's absolutely essential that the
old person in US dies yes and also very
important
it's not on your own
no it's hit in with Christ in God in God
so when Christ who is our life shall
appear then shall ye also appear with
him in glory now Glory always refers to
the character of God very important
so in other words the character that you
have to emulate here on Earth is the
character of God and as we've seen the
character of God is portrayed in his
Commandments and that will give glory to
him that'll give glory to him
so how do you achieve that you have to
modify there for your members
which are upon the Earth so if your
stomach tells you what it craves
you tell it no I'm going to give you
what's good for you
right I'm going to make it so palatable
that you enjoy it I don't have to be a
martyr as far as that is concerned
because obviously God created to be
enjoyed but the final details
uh the discernment of the palate
has to be retrained
from the harsh
rock music that it was used to that's it
to the final Melodies of the food and
it's daintier aspects
and you have to forgo fornication
leave your neighbor's wife alone you're
going to hurt your neighbor
uncleanness
when you watch television or you switch
on something unsavory
what your eyes Feast on the Mind becomes
contaminated with
so stay away from uncleanness
inordinate affections
evil concupiscence
covetousness
all of these are idolatry hmm so Martin
does god require a change change what
you listen to what you watch what you do
how you speak now isn't it interesting
that if people practice all of these
things everybody is angry with them
but they don't want to do it themselves
yeah
for which things sake the wrath of God
cometh on the children of Disobedience
so the wrath of God
applies to the children of Disobedience
whether they be in the world or whether
they be in the church God is not going
to make a difference no the standard
is the Commandments
all right in which he also walked
sometime when he lived in them so we
were children of Disobedience and we did
all of those things
and we'd have to stop doing them
but now he also put off all these things
so anger Wrath
malice
blasphemy Martin do you struggle with
anger
yes okay but at least you're honest
at least with God it can be
overcome God has righteous anger we
often have unrighteous Anglers that is a
problem but I will always and I'll say
it again
if you ask God God help me with my anger
he's not going to take everything that
causes anger away no he's going to
especially expose you to it it's going
to become your training that's Roth
now the wrath of God as we have seen is
tempered with Mercy
their iniquity is not yet full I'll give
them 400 years then I'll then it's done
then I'll wipe them out
our wrath is often untempered with Mercy
malice blasphemy filthy communication
out of your mouth
I listened to
conversations sometimes and every second
word is a swear word
I used to speak like that I used to as
well you did and now your ears hurt when
you sit in a conversation like okay so
yeah it's possible for God to change you
right
lie not one to another seeing that you
have put off the old man with his deeds
the modern all of these things lying is
a part of the Ten Commandments yes
filthy communication out of your mouth
is it part of the seventh command
blasphemy is the part of The
Commandments
anger wrath doesn't the Bible equate
anger and wrath with murder so part of
The Commandments
sir Martin what is this telling you come
into harmony with what with God's
character and that is keeping his
Commandments okay and have put on the
new man which is renewed in knowledge
after the image of him that created him
so is God a wrathful deity or is God a
just God a merciful god with a very
distinct standard and he tells you to
come into harmony with it that's it and
if you don't then you choose death that
you choose death and to do it is for
your own benefit for your own good
correct so if if the Heavenly Society is
going to be without malice without all
of these things then everybody who
practices them must be removed that's it
and they're not going to be put in hell
to rest forever they're going to be gone
yeah for us again it's their own choice
God does not interfere with the choice
he tells you okay this is the best for
you but choose if you want to but if you
don't you're gonna have to live with the
consequences or for that matter not live
okay
now the Bible calls this work of God of
executing Justice
calls it a strange work
Isaiah 28 21 for the Lord shall rise up
as in Mount perazim
it shall be wrath as in the valley of
gibeon that he may do his work he's
strange work
and bring to past his act his strange
Act
in other words God is a god of love God
is a god of Life he's not a god of death
so when he actually
exercises this Wrath
it's with a tear in his eye
it's a strange act it's contrary to his
character I think in job it says
something similar let me just grab I
think it's Job 31 or 30 30 something let
me just look at job
ah yes it's job 31.
from verse 1.
and job says I made a covenant with mine
eyes
it's a very nice way of saying I'm not
going to look at anything bad or filthy
I'm going to guard The Avenues of my
mind
I made a covenant with mine eyes why
then should I think upon a maid
there goes pornography right
for what portion of God is there from
above and what inheritance of the
almighty from on high in other words if
I transgress what will be the
consequences
is not destruction to the wicked
and a strange punishment to the workers
of iniquity
yeah that's exactly the same thing it's
a strange here you have it in the Book
of Job there you have it in Isaiah it is
not God's will to destroy no it's God's
will to make people realize
that there are rules
and there is a standard of righteousness
so Deuteronomy 31 verse 12 gather the
people together men and women and
children and the strike thy stranger
that is within thy Gates so who is
supposed to be involved in this message
everyone every single one there's nobody
excluded that they may hear and that
they may learn and fear the lord your
God and observe to do all the words of
this law
it's the bottom line it's a theme
throughout the Bible
and Romans 6 23 for the wages of Sunny's
death but the gift of God is eternal
life through Jesus Christ Our Lord is
that a choice yeah
there's a choice there right you have a
choice so whose responsibility is it if
the wrath of God is poured out upon you
your own
then who's the tyrant
you are absolutely yourself you are the
Tyrant you have brought this upon
yourself if you take a garden and you
start shooting innocent people all
around you you have brought it upon
yourself that you're going to be taken
out that's your choice
is this a wrathful deity or is this a
sound lawmaker
and enforcer yeah
definitely sound is it tempered with
Mercy yes will there be a lot of
negotiation to try and make it change
your mind yes will there be is The
Negotiator then evil and if the
negotiation fails and he takes you out
is he the villain no who's the villain
you yourself
Ezekiel 18 31 cast away from you all
your transgressions whereby ye have
transgressed and make you a new heart
and a new spirit for why will you die o
House of Israel can you see the
negotiator and he's crying actually he's
asking why listen put that gun down stop
killing innocent people
start doing what is right please I don't
want to kill you
huh
he's actually not killing you you're
killing yourself correct Ezekiel 33 11
say unto them as I live says the Lord
God I have no pleasure in the death of
the wicked but that the wicked turned
from his way and live turn ye turn ye
from your evil ways for why will you die
a house of Israel what kind of a
negotiator is this
hmm
if you cannot actually see that even
where he says I command you to keep the
Commandments it is because I want you to
turn from your evil ways and I want you
to live
all right now when it does his strange
act that is
the execution
John 11 35 the shortest verse in the
Bible Jesus wept
what does that tell you about the
character of God
it's a loving character it's a
caring character okay
uh why did he weep
because he saw that the world does not
want to listen okay oh Jerusalem
Jerusalem thou that kill us the prophets
and stone of them which are sent unto
thee how often would I have gathered thy
children together even as a hen gather
as her chickens under her wings and you
would not were they destroyed yeah
did he weep yes did he prevent the
destruction
no no
no
he warned and warned and said to them
this is what's going to happen
is there any change in this God of the
New Testament as opposed to the god of
the Old Testament no and that will be
the same at the end so Martin
people that claim that the god of the
Old Testament
is the Tyrant and the god of the New
Testament is the wishy-washy nobody
are they correct no no they haven't made
a deep study of it right and the problem
lies not with the god
but it lies with self all right now this
message must go out to the world
and Martin what if I tell you that the
message is actually portrayed in the
third angel
I know would you believe it I I'm sure
we can find out all right Revelation 14
9 and the third Angel followed them
saying with a loud voice if any man
worship the Beast and His Image and
receive his Mark in his forehead on his
hand the same shall drink of the wine of
the wrath of God
which is poured out without mixture into
the cup of his indignation and he shall
be tormented with fire and brimstone in
the presence of the Holy Angels and in
the presence of the Lamb was Sodom and
Gomorrah tormented with fire and
brimstone yes
was it destroyed yes how long did the
people suffer
they were gone gone how long did it take
for Lot's wife to turn into a pillar of
salt immediately okay so in other words
when God's Wrath is poured out when they
have passed the point of no return
then will it be because he never
exposed them to their problem no never
did any pleading on their behalf no it's
been merciful for more than 400 years
all right third Angel followed saying
with a loud voice if any man worship the
Beast
I really want to know who the Beast is
but we again but if means there's a
choice yes
or the image
or you receive the mark
then you have rejected God and the wrath
of God will be poured out on you it's a
warning to the world
here's a quote from the book Patriarchs
and Prophets
from the opening of the great
controversy it has been Satan's purpose
to misrepresent God's character
and to excite Rebellion against his law
Martin has he been successful yes for
almost 6 000 years he's been very
successful okay
and to think that he used the
institution
the church to change God's law and to
teach others to do the same that's
horrendous because I'm the Lord I change
not
and this work
appears to be crowned with success the
multitudes give ear to Satan's
deceptions and set themselves against
God
but amid the working of evil God's
purposes move steadily forward to their
accomplishment to all created
intelligences he makes manifest his
Justice and benevolence there you have
those two you cannot separate the two
from each other
through Satan's Temptations the whole
human race have become transgressors of
God's law
but by the sacrifice of his son away is
opened whereby they may return to God
through the grace of Christ they may be
enabled to render obedience to The
Father's Law
thus in every age from the midst of
apostasy and Rebellion God gathers out
the people that are true to him a people
in whose heart is his law is that in
harmony with what we just read
everything all the scripture tells us
if you want to be in harmony with God's
character you have to obey his law
here's another quote from Christ's
object lessons
behold says the scripture the darkness
shall cover the Earth and gross Darkness
the people do we have that situation no
I think everybody can acknowledge that
it's turning very dark
but the Lord shall arise upon thee and
His glory shall be seen upon thee
it is the darkness of misapprehension of
God that is enshrouding the world men
are losing their knowledge of his
character
he has been misunderstood and
misinterpreted
modern is this true
at this time a message from God is to be
proclaimed the message Illuminating in
its influence and saving in its power is
character is to be made known into the
darkness of the world is to be shed the
light of his glory that's his character
the light of his goodness his mercy and
his truth and that message is threefold
it sounds harsh yeah if you don't do it
you've got to be destroyed the wrath of
God is going to be poured out people to
see what that message is and that's the
Three Angels messages and there's
another quote from Christ objects
lessons those who wait for the
bridegrooms coming or to say to the
people behold your God
the last rays of merciful light the last
message of Mercy to be given to the
world is a revelation of his character
of love
so the Three Angels messages are a
revelation of the character of Love Will
the world gladly accept them no well
some accept that they will it's a
warning message it's a warning and it
requires a change of heart
the children of God are to manifest his
glory that means they must manifest his
character that means they must be in
harmony with his law
in their own life and character they are
to reveal what the grace of God has done
from for them in other words change them
from lawlessness to law for
this is the message that has to be
brought to the world
and it sounds like a harsh myth missing
and it will be misinterpreted well but
it is a message of Love yeah it's a
message of calling people back into
harmony with God into his character and
it is a message calling you back into
harmony with his will which has been
portrayed in this book
and has been given as a gift to us yes
so Martin that is the story of his
character now we've only used a few
examples in the Bible we could use many
many examples but the basic Essence will
remain the same and until we studied
this through
God's character will be misunderstood
and unfortunately
the churches in the world are doing a
good job of
misapplying the scriptures
even going so far as to remove the loom
now we see what that does in the world
when you remove the law you have chaos
it brings Darkness it brings darkness
and God is permitting an object lesson
to take place in front of our eyes and
humanity is going to jump onto a
bandwagon and accept a set of norms and
standards which are not scriptural but
come from the minds of men yeah may God
give us wisdom to portray the character
of God as it is portrayed in the word in
his law we need to be people of the book
amen let's pray
Heavenly Father
your character lies on the highways of
this world trampled into dust
and you have called a people to
represent you
and to set the record straight and Lord
you use urine people
you use people that have come from the
very depths of depravity
and you send them into the world to
restore the character of God what a
privilege
allow us to be part of that processes my
prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign